I just was so afraid to be broke bro I
got I was like man I ain't I love home
where I grew up at but I ain't coming
back bro that was a non-negotiable for
me
welcome to the reunion where former
athletes meet up to talk about life
money and sports
how you guys doing today good
outstanding my brother I love it look
I'm excited to jump into the
conversation we're gonna get real candid
and real real we're all former players
here so the Keo spikes Antonio Cromartie
two NFL Hall of Fame nominees we're
going to talk about literally everything
to get it started
we'll start with you Antonio tell me
what your financial situation was like
growing up
I grew up in a single parent home my mom
was a track star she was highly
recruited had me at 16. stopped
everything well I three other siblings I
didn't know my dad I was probably about
five or six years old so like for me it
was just like my mom worked two or three
jobs we will check the check
barely we had to figure out whether
we're gonna eat or turn the lights on
and I was basically the man of the house
because my mom was always working so I
had to grow up fast my first real
financial literacy was probably when I
got in the league I was fortunate enough
to grow up in a two-parent home the
thing that I remember taking away which
really helped me as I got older my mom
was when she was an educator but she was
being on just understanding like just
finances we had everything
we need it but we definitely didn't have
everything we wanted at what point do
you remember you looking at the game of
football it's not just a game you were
playing but something that you're like
yo There's an opportunity here to change
my life because I never wanted to listen
to Somebody praise me I really didn't
know how good I was yeah until my junior
year and so we got an SEC Championship
game played against Peyton Manning I put
it down bro like I had a hell of a game
let me take my talents on to the NFL
what do you remember most about this
point in time
yeah set quickly always trying to go out
and prove that I was the best and I
wanted everybody in the nation to know
it the South got something to say man so
you know for me it was just like
steadily going out just trying to prove
like I am that dude and I'm here to stay
when you're in college when did it click
for you then to say okay this is what
I'm doing that was fresh me up okay this
is my goal I have my goal set I didn't
drink
at in the party I didn't do none of that
in college business it was all business
for me
what was your recruitment process like
man it was fine
I'm gonna tell you that it was fun I
mean yeah I was the number six Corner in
the country and the number five
receiving the country and at both
positions at both positions so it's just
like for me it was a recruiting process
so I could have went to any school I
wanted to
oh
what's your perspective on uh College
athletes today to have the opportunity
for nil when I even go through
recruiting and talking to kids I told
them to stop looking for the money give
back to community I get it like you 16
17 18 years old find some of the senior
people who came up the same way who came
through the same ranks who went out and
had go to Vegas and and do it like none
other they'd be like hey man I'm not
telling you you shouldn't go to Vegas or
you shouldn't spend this amount but what
I am telling you is the power is in
numbers not just in financials but also
making decisions honestly everything
that I've done I love people to say like
hey man I'm proud of everything you're
doing I would love to say that I knew
the only reason I'm able to do what I do
is because I have a brother who lived my
life 10 years ahead of me so my older
brother our Trail was the second round
pick him in Tequila we're in the same
draft class and I got to see front row
as you're getting drafted right like all
this money is coming in who you
depending anyone for guidance I had to
depend on my my parents they had the
template you know to be able to direct
me in the right position you will never
go broke if you don't spend it I
understood the importance of credit I
just was so afraid to be broke bro I got
I was like man I ain't I love home where
I grew up at but I ain't coming back bro
like I just that that was a
non-negotiable for me so it was always
checks and balances I had somebody but I
ain't listening you wasn't listening
five-year 12.7 deal my rookie deal bro I
have nothing to show for it hmm
nothing
like nothing at all for that first deal
I have a financial about it supposed to
like hey we got we're gonna have set up
a plan we're gonna do this
wasn't that they were so afraid to lose
me as a client that they would rather
let me spend the thing on money than
rather advise me on the money
and it wasn't until I switched over to
my second financial advisor
that helped me like if you don't want to
be broke this is what you got to try to
do so luckily I was talented enough to
get to that second that third and that
fourth and fifth deal so it was just
like for me it was just like okay we at
this point so now what do I need to do
he broke it down and it was like okay
we're gonna follow the plan we decided
we're going to do things that's what we
need to try to do during that time is
when I actually started learning how to
put my money away how to invest how to
do certain things and uh he's the one
that told me what was your purchase
that was your biggest regret in that
12.7 million dollar contract everything
spent 300 000 in a jury
buying five cars like going into my
account like hey I need 80k about to go
shopping I need no they Decay to go
shopping ain't never had 80k to go
shopping did you have any purchases you
regretted with that first contract yep
[Laughter]
they bought some fur coats
I bought them too
chilling everything the big thing that I
used to do that I knew what what was my
advice I just felt like man whenever I
go travel somewhere I gotta have the
best of everything
magic you know gotta be in first class
because you care what everybody else say
about you when you get enough as you
guys inch towards retirement when you
made that decision was it
did you feel like you were forced to
make that decision or
were you in a space to be like okay hey
I'm I'm done with the game I did even
though I got I didn't realize the last
game that I played in the last game was
the last game I sustained two
concussions I tore my bicep I was like
man I can't keep putting my body through
this and so
you know after the season I still had an
opportunity to play with two more teams
I'm not gonna go to keep killing my body
and at the end of the year I don't have
nothing to show for it you know outside
of just the money at that's when you get
the later in years that you play the
money ain't enough yeah the money ain't
definitely ain't enough did you guys
think about the financial implications
that came along with your career being
done it's that team that you build
around you that helps you have success
so you don't have to worry about the
financial part of it me and my wife we
built that my word was okay what the
hell I'm gonna do all my time not
worried about the the financial part
because I was already taken care of and
we was able to do invest and do the
things that we're supposed to do so you
both have reset you have a budding
broadcasting career you a coaching
career where do you guys want to be in
10 years what do you want to have
accomplished in the next 10 years I say
in 10 years I gave myself four years to
be a head coach if I don't set it then
what it's going to be you know I believe
um
the knowledge the understanding of the
game or what I want as a coach
that's what's going to help
and what I know that I need from other
coaches to bring in the right guys
understanding guys have a relationship
with the guys not
treat guys with transactions
over the next 10 years I want to be able
to have that as a head coach and be a
mentor and still teach guys that I've
been teach for the last four or five
years just in the broadcasting career I
don't plan on doing it forever
say at least 10 years that's kind of
like
you know my cap on it and throughout the
10 years
I would love to win an Emmy just really
sharing stories
of our perspective you know people who
went through it
not just black or white but really just
telling the real truth the authenticity
keeping that inside of the story that's
the reason why I created behind the mask
to be able to to get us Brothers
ladies talking about you know their
experiences and allowing them to be the
author of their own autobiography that's
deep well both your stories are going to
help people much continue success to
both you to Keo appreciate it
appreciation Antonio it's been a
pleasure